Schön.
Ja.
Schönen guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Issa Alton. Ich bin der Diensthabender in dieser Praxis.
Und ich möchte heute mit Ihnen dieses Aufnahmegesprach dürfen.
Ist das in Ordnung so für Sie?
Ja.
Okay. Ja. Wenn Sie nicht verstehen oder Fragen haben, lassen Sie es mich wissen und Ihre Fragen so beantworten.
Und ich werde Ihnen so nächstes eine wichtige Person nicht fragen stellen, dann so Ihren Beschwerden übergehen.
Sind Sie dann verstanden?
Ja.
Okay, wunderbar.
Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Ich heiße Susanne Meyerhoff.
Susanne Meyerhoff.
Am Ende Noah F. oder WF?
2F.
Meyerhoff.
Okay.
Könnt ihr Sie bitte Ihren Namen langsam buchen?
Susanne schreibt sich S-U-S-A-E-A-N-N-E.
Susanne.
Okay.
Dann Meyerhoff. M-E-I-E-R-H-O-F-F.
Meyerhoff.
Okay. Frau Meyerhoff.
Ja.
Richtig. Okay. Frau Meyerhoff. Könnten Sie mir Ihr Geburtstatement per Ratten?
Ja. Das ist der 12. Oktober 1977.
77. Okay.
Frau Meyerhoff. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ungefahr.
46.
Okay.
Darf ich fragen, wie schwer sind Sie und wie groß sind Sie?
59 Kilo.
Ich bin 1,50 m groß.
60 m groß.
Okay.
Frau Meyerhoff.
Was für eine Summe? Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, also ich habe beobachtet, dass ich in den letzten Wochen sehr schnell
und sehr oft erschöpft bin.
Ich bin nervös, bin stark schnell gereizt.
Lasst mich schnell irgendwie provozieren.
Das kenne ich nicht bei mir.
Ich bin sonst eher ruhig, aber ich bin sehr nervös und gereizt
in den letzten Wochen.
Ich schwitze sehr stark.
Okay.
Frau Meyerhoff, haben Sie auch Schmerzen oder nicht?
Schmerzen habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Und so?
Hatten Sie schon einmal so etwas erlebt?
Oder ist das zum ersten Mal?
Nein, so etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Ja, gehabt.
Letzten, Letzten Mocha. Ja, richtig.
Frau Meyerhoff, haben Sie irgendwelche Schwellung
oder Vergrößerung im Hals bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Schwellung, Vergrößerung, nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Heiserkeit oder Vergrößerung?
Nein.
Sie sind bei Ihnen, sind Ihnen eine Sittern oder Heiser Unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Ich habe es beobachtet, dass meine Hände und Finger in den letzten Wochen stärker zittern.
Das stimmt.
Sittern.
Ja.
Okay.
Und Frau Meyerhoff, sind Ihnen eine trockene Haut oder feuchte Haut bekannt?
Ich muss viel schwitzen.
Schwitzen.
Ich schwitze viel und ich glaube, meine Haut fühlt sich immer so warm an.
Warm?
Ja.
Und auch...
Wenn andere Leute einen Pullover anziehen, dann habe ich nur ein T-Shirt an,
weil ich friere dann nicht.
Haben Sie eine Probleme, Durchfall oder Verstoffung?
Normalerweise habe ich immer ganz regelmäßigen Stuhlgang.
In den letzten Wochen habe ich häufiger Durchfall.
Durchfall.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Beruhige Nagel?
Oder?
Wie bitte?
Beruhige Nagel?
Bin ich?
Nein.
Beruhige Nagel.
Ja, Herr Meyerhoff.
Frau Meyerhoff.
Meyerhoff.
Ja.
So, haben Sie Fieber oder haben Sie Ihre Körperfieber gemessen?
Fieber habe ich nicht gemessen, aber wie gesagt, meine Haut fühlt sich immer sehr warm an.
Sehr warm an.
Okay.
Und haben Sie dann Augen, eine ungewöhnliche Bemerkung?
Ich meine hervorstrittenen Augenapfel oder zurückliegende Augenapfel oder Lidsenkung?
Ja, habe ich jetzt so nicht bemerkt.
Ich habe manchmal den Eindruck, dass meine Augen so etwas empfindlicher sind.
Empfindlicher.
Ich muss die Augen häufig mal so mit den Händen reiben mit den Fingern.
Das habe ich bemerkt, aber sonst habe ich nichts bemerkt in den Augen.
Okay.
Wurden Sie schon einmal Ihre Schilddrüse-Funktion kontrolliert?
Schilddrüse?
Ja.
Aber nicht.
Vielleicht hat früher der Arzt mal Blut untersucht, aber meine Schilddrüse hat noch nie Probleme gemacht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Konzentrationsstörungen?
Konzentrationsstörungen?
Ja.
Ja, gut.
In den letzten Wochen, ich fühle mich halt sehr schnell erschöpft und da habe ich auch Konzentrationsstörungen.
Okay.
Ja, so.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ich kann immer essen.
Okay.
Haben Sie im Laufe da seit ab oder so genommen?
Also in den letzten drei Monaten habe ich ungefähr 6 kg abgenommen.
6 kg abgenommen.
Ja.
Aber Sie leiden unter Durchfall seit letzten Wochen.
Richtig?
Ja, also in den letzten Wochen habe ich das bemerkt, dass ich häufiger Durchfall habe.
Das habe ich vorher nie gehabt.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, das ist ein chronisches Problem.
Ich hatte als Kind häufig Blasenentzündungen und auch Nierenbeckenentzündungen.
Okay.
Letzt hatte ich eine Nierenbeckenentzündung vor 3 Jahren und bin regelmäßig in urologischer Kontrolle.
Ja.
Haben Sie Probleme durchzuschlafen oder einzuschlafen?
Normalerweise nicht, aber eben in den letzten Wochen ist mein Schlaf nicht gut.
Da mache ich oft auf in der Nacht.
Okay.
So, Frau Bayer-Kopf, haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Herz schlanger, langsamer oder schneller schlägt?
Schlägt.
Also ich glaube, mein Herz schlägt schneller.
Ich habe eine Zeit lang immer so meinen Puls gemessen, weil ich auch sonst immer Sport mache.
Aber in den letzten Wochen fühle ich mich dazu nicht in der Lage.
Normalerweise ist mein Puls immer so bei 60, 65.
Jetzt ist er mehr so bei 100.
Bei 100.
Okay.
Ja.
Haben Sie Atemnot oder Atemnevangelosch?
Also ich habe ein allergisches Asthma.
Das habe ich schon seit der Kindheit, seit der Jugend.
Auf Hausstaub und auch auf einige Pollen.
Und bin auch schon mal desensibilisiert worden, aber das hat nicht viel Erfolg gebracht.
Ich muss da auch immer Spreis nehmen.
Okay.
Ja, Frau Bayer-Kopf, Sie haben gesagt, Blassen und Nierenbeckenentsunnung und Asthma,
leiden Sie andere chronische Erkrockung?
Nein.
Okay.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, als Kind bin ich an den Mandeln operiert worden.
Und vor zehn Jahren bin ich an den Kieferhöhlen operiert worden,
weil ich oft Nasen, Nebenhöhlen, Entzündungen hatte.
Und da wurde hier an der Kieferhöhle irgendwo, hieß es, eine Art Fenster gemacht.
Dass vielleicht der Schlein besser da rauslaufen kann.
Und danach wurde das besser.
Danach habe ich nicht mehr so oft da Entzündungen gehabt an den Nasen-Nebenhöhlen.
Haben Sie Probleme bei Nasen-Nebenhöhlen oder eine Sehnt- oder Denthal-Probleme?
Also Nasen-Nebenhöhle, die waren oft entzündet, wenn ich erkältet war im Winter und so.
Und da war es häufig so, dass der als Nasen-Ohrenarzt wohl gesagt hat,
dass das hauptsächlich in der Kieferhöhle hier ist.
Da für die Schleim ist oder so.
Und dann musste das operiert werden, aber das ist danach besser geworden.
Okay.
Vor zehn Jahren, richtig?
Ja.
Okay.
Und Pro-Meyer-Hoff, nehmen Sie eine Irgendweltschein mit die Kommentare regelmäßig ein.
Oder bei Bedarf?
Ja, gegen das Astma, da nehme ich Spreis.
Das war auf verschiedene.
Benutzen Sie Spray regelmäßig?
Ja.
Wissen Sie, was das heißt?
Ja, das eine Medikament heißt Viani.
Das schreibt V-I-A-N-I.
Das nehme ich ein bis zweimal pro Tag, je nachdem, wie es geht.
Gerade jetzt im Frühjahr, wenn viele Pollen fliegen,
dann muss ich das zweimal am Tag nehmen.
Und sonst habe ich früher, immer wenn ich Sport gemacht habe,
habe ich auch noch Bero Dual Spray genommen.
Bero Dual.
Ja, Bero Dual.
Und das habe ich in letzter Zeit aber nicht mehr genommen,
weil ich zuletzt kein Sport mehr gemacht habe.
Benutzen Sie die Medikament vor dem Sport?
Vor dem Sport.
Okay.
Frau Mayerhof, was machen Sie als Sport?
Joggen oder?
Joggen mache ich und etwas Krafttraining,
aber hauptsächlich joggen.
Normalerweise dreimal in der Woche.
Dreimal Woche.
Gut.
Okay.
Frau Mayerhof, Sie haben gegen Polenallergie
und Sie leiten an Asthma.
Haben Sie eine andere Allergie oder Vertragigkeit?
Haustop.
Ja, Haustop ist das Schlimmste.
Okay.
Und eine Lebensmittel oder nicht?
Liebete.
Haben Sie gegen Lebensmittel und Verträglichkeit oder nicht?
Nein, nicht mit dem.
Nein.
Okay.
Ja, Frau Mayerhof, was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Sekretärin bei einem Steuerberater.
Steuer.
Okay.
Darf ich fragen, wie ist Ihr Familienstand,
sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet und habe ein Kind, 20 Jahre alt,
das Kind ist gesund.
Gesund, gut.
Wollen Sie mit zusammen?
Nein, ich wohne mit meinem Mann zusammen,
weil die Tochter ist inzwischen ausgezogen, die studiert.
Ja, Frau Mayerhof, ich möchte über Ihre Eltern sprechen.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, der Vater ist 82 Jahre alt.
82 Jahre alt?
Ja, hohen Blutdruck.
Die Mutter ist 81 Jahre alt, die leidet auch unter Asthma.
Asthma.
Und hat Arthrose im Stärke, Arthrose im rechten Knie.
Okay.
Ihre Mutter, wo ist Ihre Mutter,
vegan, arthros operiert oder?
Nein, ich bin noch nicht.
Nein, Sie wollen sich nicht operieren lassen.
Sagt Sie, da bin ich zu alt.
Okay.
Ja, Frau Mayerhof, ich habe ein paar Fragen.
Ihre Lebensgewohnlichkeit, darf ich fragen, rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Gut.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich habe nicht jeden Tag ein bis zweimal pro Woche ein Glas Wein am Wochenende.
Wein.
Rotwein oder Waswein?
Weißwein.
Okay.
Und Frau Mayerhof, bitte nehmen Sie meine nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Putinerfrage.
Nehmen Sie meine Drogen?
Nein.
Ja, Frau Mayerhof, ich bin mit meinem Fragen fertig.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie eine Frage?
Ja, ich bin natürlich unruhig, was das sein kann,
weil so etwas habe ich ja noch nie gehabt.
Was kann das sein?
Aber das werden Sie jetzt sicherlich untersuchen.
Ja, Frau Mayerhof, natürlich zurzeit,
ich kann nicht eine richtige Diagnose stellen,
aber natürlich, ich habe eine Verdacht.
Und so, ich werde die körperliche Untersuchung,
vor allem Haltsuntersuchung, durchführen.
Dann, ich werde ihnen Blut abnehmen, um Labor zu untersuchen.
Dann können wir ihre Diagnose sprechen,
aber sie sollen in Krakenhaus bleiben.
Aber ich werde auch schilddrüse Unterfunktionen.
Aber wie ich gesagt habe, das ist eine Verdacht.
Sind Sie damit zufrieden?
Okay, vielen Dank.
Gut, prima.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Ja, ich möchte fragen,
ob es Ihnen etwas passiert,
dass Sie eine Woche zu Ihrem Beschwerden geführt haben?
Vor einer Woche?
Ja.
Die Beschwerden waren ja schon seit einigen Wochen.
Ich habe in drei Monaten Gewicht abgenommen.
Wenn ich mich jetzt erinnere,
war es ungefähr vier Monate, da war ich beim Urologen.
Dann hat er mich überwiesen zum Radiologen.
Da wurde eine Konfastmitteluntersuchung gemacht an der Niere.
Das war vor ungefähr vier Monaten.
Aber ich kann mich sonst nicht erinnern, was sonst passiert ist.
Haben Sie schon Nacht Schweißbemerk?
Vorhin nicht.
Jetzt habe ich aber starkes Schwitzen.
Das ist Schwitzen, ist eher auch Tag und Nacht.
Ich möchte eine Frage stellen.
Haben Sie Schlafprobleme?
Ein Schlafen oder Durchschlafen?
Durchschlafen.
Das hat der Kollege, glaube ich, gefragt.
Früher konnte ich immer gut schlafen, aber in den letzten Wochen nicht gut.
Obwohl ich sehr erschöpft bin.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ein bis zweimal in der Woche.
Ein Glas Wein.
Aber nicht jeden Tag.
Ich habe auch eine Frage.
Haben Sie eine Ausantragung?
Ja, haben Sie eine Ausantreise in der letzten Zeit gehabt?
Ich habe nicht gehört, ob es gefreut wurde.
Vor sechs Monaten habe ich eine Kreuzfahrt gemacht in der Karibik.
Da waren wir zwei Wochen auf einem Kreuzfahrtschiff.
Okay, danke.
Wenn der Kollege...
Nur die Symptome der Bio-Säßig.
Doppelbilder sehe ich hier im Chat.
Sehen Sie Doppelbilder? Nein, sehe ich nicht.
Keine Doppelbilder.
Wie oft?
Wie oft und wie euch das sich?
Es ist so unvermittelt.
Manchmal habe ich einen Tag vier, fünf Mal dünnen Stuhlgang.
Aber dann wieder einige Tage gar nicht.
Aber das war früher nicht so.
Das hat sich verändert.
Haarausfall?
Ich habe mich nicht beobachtet.
Danke schön.
Ich denke, alle Fragen, wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Und Kontrastmittel auslösen, sehr wichtige Antwort.
Und deswegen, meine Kollegen, möchte ich...
Können wir...
Arst-Hatschisch beanfangen?
Wir können gerne, aus meiner Sicht können wir gerne anfangen.
Wenn der Kollege...
Guten Tag, sehr verehrte Herr Oberarst.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Und ich möchte Ihnen die Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie Zeit für mich? Ja, habe ich.
Vielen Dank, vielen Dank Herr Oberarst.
Die Patientin heißt Susanne Meyerhoff.
Sie ist 46 Jahre alt.
Und 1,69 Meter groß.
Und 59 Kilogramm schwer.
Frau Meyerhoff stellte sich bei uns wegen, seit letzten Wochen,
eine nervöse Tat.
Und Fatig, Konzentration, Störung.
Und Fingerzimmer, oder Tramper.
Und sie, sie habe früher nicht alle Beschwerde gehabt.
Und aus erdem Leide, sie seit letzten Wochen unter
Fotopsy und begleitet von Diarrö.
Und die Patientin berichtete, dass sie innerhalb
3 Monaten 6 Kilogramm abgenommen haben.
Aber sie, sie habe keine Appetitlosigkeit.
Sondern sie habe heiß Hunger.
Und auch sie haben, sie leiden unter Insomnia durch Form, durch, durch so, durch
Störung. Und sie haben, sie haben, sie haben früher ihre, ihre
Lebensfrequenz, gemessen, normalerweise 5-6, aber seit letzten
Wochen ihre, ihre Lebensfrequenz ist 100.
Und vor Erkrockung, er seh leide an Asthma seit Kindheit.
Sie wurde Sensibilation-Störung-Therapie behandelt,
aber das hat nicht geholfen.
Und sie ist wegen Tonselektomie-Operiat als Kind,
und sie wurde für die Seniare von Maxilla Sinusitis operiert.
Und Medikamente, als sie benutze,
sie hat eine Ausstrupp-Allergie und sie ist der Sekretär
in der Arbeit von der Sekretärin.
Sie ist verheiratet und sie hat eine Tochter.
Sie wohnt mit seinem Mann zusammen.
Sie haben einen Fachausdruck für Knieartrose.
Sie ist eine Frau, sie ist nicht geholfen.
Sie trinkt nur ein bis zweimal pro Woche.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Meine Verdachtdiagnose ist hypertriose.
Sie spricht hyperhydros,
sie heißt Erschöpferkonzentration-Störung.
Gewichtabnahme?
Können Sie eventuell etwas über die Ursache dieser Hypertereose sagen?
Die Patientin hat ja eine horologische Anamnese.
Sie leitet Sistitis und Pioninephritis.
Sie ist die Patientin, die in der Kindheit kräufig Sistitis gelitten und Pioninephritis.
Und wann war die letzte Pioninephritis?
Sie berichtet, dass sie in urologischer Kontrolle ist.
Können Sie sich erinnern, was vor vier Monaten bei der Patientin gemacht wurde?
Vor vier Monaten hatte die Patientin eine Computer-Tomografie mit Kontrastmitteln.
Sie hat die Kontrastmittel und die Hypertereose enthalten.
Sie enthalten meist Kontrastmittel, aber sie enthalten wohl auch Jod.
Sie haben durch die Kontrastmitteluntersuchung eine Hypertereose.
Sie enthalten immer wieder vor.
Sie hat auch eine Hypertereose.
Sie hat eine Hypertereose.
Vor zehn Jahren konnte die Patientin nicht genau sagen,
dass sie eine Hypertereose enthalten.
Sie hat eine Hypertereose.